Howie we all need to be like Howie and
not shake hands right now right you know
what I don't shake hands and now I've
taken it to another level I don't inhale
that coronavirus Howie we all need to be
living like you but now everybody is
living like me so I'm even more
comfortable everybody's watching
everybody's aware welcome to Howie's
world he's world it's a show we all
should have been living and long ago now
if you're not inhaling how are you
judging the people on America's Got tap
don't need to inhale to judge I can
judge in a big exhale like well you were
fantastic see I love it we're so excited
I mean we just heard the screams as
Heidi and Sophia got out of their cars
and you didn't hear anything okay I'm
sorry I was nothing happened nothing
happened for me did you hear the screams
when Sophia and Heidi Sophia and Heidi
got out of the car and pardon me here's
the thing Howie they deafened us when
you got out of the car and then I had to
reset this one well that's okay I don't
need that you don't I just need the et
audience to love me that's all I needed
why we're speaking to you first but what
is it like having them as part of things
of course you're familiar with Heidi but
Sophia on the panel how's it been first
of all I I think we are the most
stunning panel on TV and Heidi Klum's
supermodel entrepreneur beautiful smart
my friend sitting right next to me and
beyond her even more beauty Sofia vegara
who's funny and beautiful and smart and
witty and just fit in like she has been
here for decades really right away what
what about her meet her fit in because
you know she's got a little sass to I
wonder if she kind of put Simon in his
place what's finished already had a
little tit for tat with Simon right away
and you know here's a woman who has been
in the business for years and is sure of
herself and powerful so she's not
intimidated and that's wonderful and she
has nothing to be intimidated about
she's more intimidating than an
intimidating oh well she's got this
amazing obtainable the the ability to go
out with a guy named him
you know I feel like with Sophia's
comedy chops and you we're gonna have
like some laughs on like you have
everything in this show there's laughter
there's tears there's excitement there's
dismay there is something for everybody
and so you guys did have I mean um you
know we've one more question my last
question of your people
I hear people signaling this is the
signal okay one more question the last
question that's gonna be asked of me it
was well well let signal the people at
home one more question okay you know
what how I'll give it to you then what's
the one last thing you want to say about
this show I want to say this is don't
miss television this is the one show
that has something for everybody and if
there's a moment that isn't titillating
to you and wonderful and exciting wait
60 seconds there's something completely
different so there's something for
everybody of every age for a from every
place a GT season 15 this summer no more
questions
[Music]